here's an interesting little sub story
to the firing of FBI director James
Comey on a Tuesday CBS News is Eliza
Palmer was rinkside yes rinkside and
asked vladimir putin about the firing of
FBI director james comey
why rinkside well let amir putin was in
a full hockey uniform with pads and
about to participate in a hockey game
his response was very odd the entire
thing is pretty surreal and i'm going to
play it for you if you're listening on
the radio or podcast and not watching
you're going to hear a third voice in
addition to putin's and the CBS
reporters which is the interpreter who
is bridging the language gap between
Putin and Eliza Palmer there's also
music blaring in the background during
this everything about this is surreal ok
let's take a look
us-russia relations together in a vacuum
well any way
then you get stolen there will be no
effect your question looks very funny
for me don't be angry with you we the
workers we have nothing to do with it if
we broke away completely and president
principal is acting an important for
this competence is important for this
war because if you quit what about us
why we LT detectives are going to be yes
I'm going to play hockey with a hockey
fan it was religious and I invite here
to do the same I'll be here I'll be
expecting a lot of Palmer should
absolutely have accepted the invitation
to join vladimir putin's hockey game
that's a major journalistic opportunity
there yeah and why so defensive there
you know she was asking how it
disaffection US relations and right
responded by saying oh we had nothing to
do with it that's not what she asked
it's very strange it's a very strange
response her questions looked funny to
Putin Putin has to be laughing at the
u.s. big time right I mean he's attacked
our voting system he's arguably helped
get a major clown elected president a
clown that disrupting our entire
government for fear of being exposed as
having colluded potentially with Russia
Vladimir Putin's got to be laughing all
the way to as I like to say the bank
could given his alleged 200 billion
dollar Network and in that hockey game
that followed he apparently scored six
or seven gold and so even at 64 years
old playing against X NHL stars yeah
went quite well from self when I hear
Putin scored seven goals I am reminded
of when Kim jong-il got nine holes in
one when he played golf the difference
being Putin really did it but obviously
is this because it's a competitive game
and Putin's really good at hockey the
way that Kim jong-il was supposedly
really good at golf I know it's not
exactly the same thing but it reminds me
of that needless to say isn't this one
of the strangest videos you've seen
lately
yeah and credit to that reporter because
as we know Russia does not have the best
reputation when it comes to dealing with
journalists right there's some bravery
there today's program is made possible
in part by Gamefly which is sort of like
netflix for
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s